no one has ever found a program of life
or a blueprint in a gene room and we've
been looking for over 20 years at
complete genome sequences
[Music]
thank you very much it may seem
utterly presumptuous for a physiologist
because that's what I am to enter the
hotly disputed philosophical area of
Free Will so I'll begin
by making two bold assertions that I
will justify during the talk the first
is that the processes by which living
organisms make choices are indeed open
to empirical investigation the relevant
questions I will show are empirical
physiological questions as much as they
are conceptual philosophical ones the
second is that these two aspects the
empirical and the conceptual are
necessarily related because we cannot
ask answer
empirical scientific questions in a
conceptual vacuum no science can exist
in a conceptual vacuum so I will not be
arguing that physiology alone can answer
all the questions independent of
philosophy but I will be arguing the
complement to that statement which is
the philosophy alone
is also inadequate to the task and I
will clarify these two statements at the
end of the presentation now the reason
or one reason why it is such a hotly
disputed area is that to many people it
may seem obvious that since organisms
are made of and evolved from chemical
compounds and systems they cannot
possibly escape from being chemically
determined
we don't expect purely chemical
processes to be capable of making
responsible decisions that's one of the
reasons why we are cautious about
approving driverless cars on our streets
the ethical and legal problems depend
not on the science or not on that
primarily but on attributing legal
responsibility whether to the owners of
the cars or to the car makers but in Co
both cases you'll notice the ultimate
responsibility is attributed to humans
not to that machine
yet I'm going to show you in this talk
that precisely because of the kinds of
chemistry that enable organisms to exist
even
let alone behave in the way they do they
cannot be determinate machines so what
exactly are we made of what is our
chemistry
well with the exception of a few Trace
elements we are largely made of the most
common chemical elements in the universe
hydrogen carbon oxygen and nitrogen just
those four
make up the vast majority of the
chemistry of our bodies now of course
they are combined in unimaginably large
number of possible ways because many of
the molecules we are made of are
polymers long strings of Highly variable
composition dnas rnas and proteins are
all long polymers threads of sequences
of either nucleotides or minor acids
your DNA and mine consists of strings of
nucleotides forming polymers around 3
billion nucleotides long
that wouldn't incidentally be enough
stuff in the whole universe for all
those possible sequences of three
billion DNA bases even to exist
now each of us might be
as I think we are highly unique and
improbable machine but we might still be
machines determined by our genes and
proteins
my demonstration that we cannot be
determined that machines begins with
just two of those four elements hydrogen
and oxygen combined they make
the smallest and the great majority of
all the molecules in our bodies H2O
water
now water is an extremely unusual
substance in the universe
it is liquid at a range of temperatures
way above the maximum temperature at
which both of its atoms could be liquids
oxygen vaporizes at minus 90 Centigrade
hydrogen minus 253 so the bonding in H2O
is responsible for an enormous increase
in the temperature of condensation now
very few other chemicals that have that
property it is also a very flexible
solvent nearly all the molecules in our
bodies can be dissolved in it but the
exception is extremely important to what
I'm going to present as my argument fats
cannot be dissolved in water
they can exist in a water suspension
every good cook knows how to make a
sauce by whisking up in oil water
suspension
but our bodies are rather different from
a source thank goodness
the facts in us are actually more like
soap bubbles
than fat globules
and those bubbles form the vast
structures of membranes in our cells and
organs furthermore
those membranes are where nearly all the
control processes which would be
relevant to choice
are to be located so how on Earth did
the genome
they're not fats
they're not in the membranes
how on Earth did they become described
as The Book of Life
creating us body and mind as Dawkins
puts it in his book The Selfish Gene if
that were so the conditional logic
necessary for life to be possible would
have to be found in the genome
now I am a computer programmer amongst
other things as well as being a
biologist if you look for all of those
if then else Clauses in a computer
program you will not find them anywhere
in your genomes no one has ever found a
program of life or a blueprint in a gene
room and we've been looking for over 20
years at complete genome sequences
there are switches in genomes absolutely
so many of them but those switches are
controlled by other physiological
processes that form the control routines
that enable choice to happen
those routines depend on the protein
channels packed into the fats the lipid
membranes they are car conditional on
off
switches and they therefore conform part
of a choice process
furthermore
those membranes and their proteins are
influenced by the electrical and
chemical processes that only membranous
systems can display and be sensitive to
without those membrane processes there
could not be choice between different
behavioral options Choice obviously
don't need a philosopher to tell you
this is an essential element in any
theory of variables reaction not
surprisingly therefore
all our nerve cells too have these
controllable on off switches so do all
the cells in our body
the possibility of systems that can make
choices therefore arose when the first
cells emerged with their membranes
during The evolutionary process that
is where intelligence became possible in
living systems what I mean by
intelligence here is the ability to
distinguish between and choose between
behavioral options just as artificial
intelligence machines do I'm not at this
stage concerned with whether those
choices are made consciously
I'm only showing that the intelligence
of life therefore lies in our membranes
and the variable processes that they
enable not in our genomes
now I haven't finished because not only
is water remarkable liquid solvent it
freezes in an unusual way
ice is lighter than liquid water
the molecules become further apart in in
ice compared to the liquid form so it
floats on our lakes and seas all other
possible solvents do the reverse
you won't find another solvent in the
universe that can do what water does
their Frozen forms would sink that fact
is why we don't expect to find living
organisms certainly not of the kind we
know here on Earth
independent of water elsewhere in the
universe
moreover since ice floats large expanses
of water in lakes and seas remain open
to living systems they continue to
flourish even beneath the ice the ice
even acts as a heat barrier because it's
a good insulator and we think that his
biologists think that is why life on
Earth survived the long periods very
long indeed when the Earth was like an
ice ball
Life as we know it may therefore Exist
Elsewhere in the solar system on planets
or moons that are completely iced over
now so far none of the properties of
water I've highlighted which are very
unusual can alone justify my argument
the living organisms can have free
choice but there is another property of
water which does form a key fact in the
argument and it was first observed in
1827 by a scientist called Robert Brown
he ground up pollen grains to form even
smaller particles pollen dust if you
like he then sprinkled that fine dust
into water under a microscope
and as he watched under the microscope
and watched the dust particles they were
all jiggling around
hardly ever stationary
nearly a century later in 1905 in one of
his classic papers Albert Einstein
showed the movements of the Dust
particles were due to their continual
buffeting by the incessant movement of
the water molecules
now I want this point I want to make two
very important points
the first is that this is not true of
solid machines like computers
the atoms in Silicon and metal
structures may be vibrating
but they are not freely engaging in the
fabulous stochasticity we observe in a
water-based environment
the suspended particles can travel over
unlimited distances many times greater
than the diameter of the particles atoms
and molecules in solids do not do that
in living systems they're doing it all
the time you can watch it you label
fluorescence
fluorescently any chemical in a living
cell you'll find it travels all the way
around the cell
the second
point is that all the molecules and
structures in our living cells are
dissolved or suspended in water
all
including the genome will be subject to
the buffeting that Robert Brown observed
in which we now call Brownian motion
well these facts form a fundamental
difference between living organisms like
us and determinate computer programs
does it matter
you bet it does
for wherever we look in our studies of
living systems we find
massive random stochastic activity there
is no way which living cells could be
exempt from Brownian motion
and importantly that is also true of our
genomes the DNA threads must also
experience these chance buffeting since
they also exist in a water-based
environment now I want to pause at this
stage in the argument to make a very
important distinction
the fact that biological molecules and
the structures they form are subject to
chemical stochasticity is not disputed
by anyone
neodywinists particularly Neo Darwin's
determinists like Jerry Coyne for
example would accept that fact just as
strongly as I do
what then is the difference between us
new Darwin is actually enthusiastically
embrace stochasticity
the random mutations in our genomes form
an essential part of their theory of
life according to them living organisms
experience this stochasticity but that
is all that they can possibly do with it
the result is that we are a subject
during The evolutionary process to what
they call blind chance
we cannot possibly help experiencing
blind chance and as organisms we have to
wait for the exceedingly slow process of
natural selection to arrive at the very
few random changes in DNA that can be
beneficial instead of being deleterious
importantly
they argue that during our lifetimes
none of those blind chance events can be
used in any functional way
as a consequence there can be no
physiological basis for free choice
based on molecular level stochasticity
and that is why Neo Darwin is like Jerry
Coyne in Chicago conclude that free
choice is just a magnificent illusion
the sentence in which he does this is so
magnificent that I have to quote it the
illusion he writes of agency is so
powerful that even strong
incompatibilities like myself he means
himself of course not me
um will always act as though we had
choices even though we don't we know
that we don't
we have no choice in the matter
but he goes on we can at least Ponder
why Evolution might have bequeathed as
such a powerful illusion now notice the
Striking contradiction
who is this we
that can ponder why because from coin's
viewpoint
why are we even capable of doing that
and to choose either to agree or
disagree with his statement but look I
will leave that contradiction to one
side I can't deal with everything in a
single talk to the IAI
because I want to explain
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas